welcome back to las vegas now september
is prostate cancer awareness month so
southwest medical connected us to dr
jeff wilson of the urology specialist of
nevada to learn more here's our
conversation
well first let's talk about what exactly
is prostate cancer
define it for us sure prostate cancer is
cancer
of the prostate gland which is located
between the bladder
and the urethra in the male the prostate
gland is responsible for
producing a fluid which nourishes the
nourishes the sperm
okay and who can actually get prostate
cancer and at what point in their lives
so only males can get prostate cancer
and
only males typically over the age of 50
years old
with increasing prevalence over the age
of 60 and even into the 70s
african american males and men with
certain genetic mutations
are at higher risk of getting prostate
cancer okay and what are the symptoms
and what should people look out for
prostate cancer in its early stages
actually has no symptoms at all
in the later stages prostate cancer can
have
either bone pain or lower abdominal pain
but those are only in the
more advanced stages okay and how can
you get screenings or testings
to see you know what what's going on in
your body
so the tests that we do to diagnose
prostate cancer include a digital rectal
exam
performed by the urologist in the office
to look for firm areas of the prostate
that may be at higher risk of prostate
cancer and also
lab work in the form of prostate
specific antigen or
psa testing from the lab
in addition we have started to use
prostate mri
to localize more specific lesions to
biopsy in the office
ultimately only an office biopsy is
diagnostic
okay and if you if you are doing these
screening tests is it because
you are feeling something or is because
it's it's standard you should do it over
the course of time
so we recommend routine screening for
most men after age 50 years old
and that's typically performed by the
primary care physician
if there's an elevation in those levels
or concern
with the digital rectal exam the patient
is referred to the urologist for
further workout okay and now let's talk
about treatment options what can people
actually get done prostate cancer is a
complex
process and involves a thorough
discussion between the urologist and the
patient
or lower risk prostate cancer the
options include
active surveillance which is close
observation or
a prostatectomy which is most often
performed robotically nowadays
or radiation therapy to the prostate
with all of that said i think if we're
spreading awareness about prostate
cancer it's really important to
tell people to talk to their doctor
about it right
oh absolutely yeah talking to your
physician and having open communication
crucial to optimize care especially if
you're at higher risk okay thank you so
much dr wilson
thank you so much for having me today of
course
we want to thank southwest medical for
being one of our community pride
partners
lindsey i'll send it to you